el 6 de enero los tres reyes magos
recorren el mundo católico Para repartir
regalos pasan claro por América Latina
en Caracas la capital de Venezuela
Melchor Gaspar y Baltasar fueron hasta
una comunidad de la etnia indígena wayú
no vivía mucha pobreza y nunca tuve una
alegría así como esta de que alguien me
diera algo de los Reyes Magos y por eso
lo hago porque me llenaba a los niños
más necesitados Los Reyes también se
dejaron ver por Buenos Aires la capital
de Argentina primero en carroza y
después se hicieron fotos con los más
pequeños todavía quedan argentinos que
reivindican esta tradición Este es un
festejo que era mucho más importante que
Papá Noel y donde los chicos realmente
el regalo importante de lo recibían para
reyes
el 6 de enero es el Día de la epifanía y
en Bolivia van más allá de los reyes en
la paz se fusiona la tradición española
con la indígena y los feligreses llevan
a la iglesia figuras del Niño Jesús en
ropa de satén y bordados en oro una
reliquia que se transmite de generación
en generación más de 50 años es una
trayectoria increíble porque este niño
llegó de Alemania
sincretismo que llega hasta México en el
estado de Chiapas indígenas
danzaron el baile del Torito en honor al
niño Dios nuestros antepasados lo
dejaron así como algo único para ser
representado por estas fechas una
tradición que igual que las culturas en
América Latina evolucionáis enriquece Y
en este caso con un claro objetivo dar
por terminada la Navidad